[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a closer look at the parkland school
shooter's developmental years would you
describe nicholas as a bully no
he was so consumed with
being liked and wanting people to like
them plus a massive indictment of more
than two dozen people in atlanta
following a four-year investigation into
celebrity home invasions and more of r
kelly's accusers testify at his federal
trial in chicago recounting their
experiences with the disgraced r b
singer but first this is the biggest
case to hit this county
certainly in a century
maybe even more jury selection winds
down as ohio attorneys prepare to
present their case in the pike county
massacre trial of george wagner iv law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
welcome everybody to law and crime daily
i'm jesse weber day two of jury
selection is underway in the trial of
george wagner iv in ohio's pike county
massacre wagner's brother jake and
mother angela have already pled guilty
and said that the family planned the
murders to get full custody of a
daughter that he shared with hannah
rhoden long crimes angenette levy tells
us what we know about the jury so far
both the state and the defense used
their six strikes to eliminate jurors
that they didn't want so the jury is
made up of nine women and three men
six alternates will also be chosen this
is the biggest case to hit this county
certainly in a century maybe even more
mark weaver is a former deputy attorney
general for the state of ohio and has
seen the interests the rodent and gilly
murders have drawn to an area that has a
lot of challenges
so this is a rural
appalachian
poor white county
in south southern part of ohio this case
rocked the region when this happened the
notion of going in and killing everybody
except the babies including a couple of
teenagers really got people's attention
but that's what prosecutors say happened
on april 22 2016. eight members of the
rhoden and gilley families murdered many
of them shot in the head as they slept
with children and babies by their sides
forensics such as ballistics and shoe
print evidence will be part of what the
jury sees
there is no perfect crime and this crime
is certainly not perfect they there will
be enough evidence here that will
certainly uh keep the jury engaged
throughout this entire process jurors
will be taken to the four crime scenes
involved in this case and they will also
visit the former home of the wagners
they'll also get to see the flying w
farm which is a sprawling horse farm
owned by jake and george wagner's
grandmother that farm was searched
several times opening statements are set
for the day after labor day for law and
crime daily i'm angenette levy
all right let's break this down joining
us today is criminal defense attorney
mike corbanix and co-host terry austin
it's great to have you both here terry
i'll start with you as you heard from
anjanette the jurors are going to visit
these four properties involved with the
crime but is it really necessary for
them to visit all of these areas and how
do you think that's going to impact them
overall
i actually don't think it's necessary
and as a matter of fact i think it's
going to have a huge impact it will
absolutely help the prosecution and
that's why they are doing it and the
defendant i think is going to be hurt by
this when you take those jurors out
there they are putting themselves in
that crime scene and they're having a
bird's eye view they're going to imagine
what really happened when the crime took
place and they're going to the actual
homes where they were shot remember
these folks were shot in the head while
they were asleep and they were sleeping
next to very young people in those beds
little like you know toddlers so and as
we heard they were teenagers who were
shot i think the youngest one was 15 or
16. so this is a very gruesome crime and
for a fact when those jurors go out
there they're going to feel it and
they're going to relive it and they are
definitely going to help the prosecution
as far as that's concerned yeah it
definitely paints a picture in their
mind mike so we're expecting jake to
testify and it's part of this plea deal
to avoid the death penalty for himself
and the others that were involved but
what happens if the prosecution thinks
that he's not being truthful on the
stand
well that would be a violation of the
agreement of a cooperation agreement
where he says he will be truthful if
that occurs
more
most likely what would happen is his
guilty plea would remain but he would be
open to an open sentencing since he
didn't live up to his obligation so he
could be looking at a maximum sentence
in addition he could be charged with
perjury
and the death penalty might be taken off
the table as part of that deal which is
the very thing that he was hoping to
avoid for him and his family members so
it's clearly in his best interest as it
would be for everybody that takes a sort
of deal to testify truthfully when that
time comes we're going to switch over
now to california where testimony
continues into its seventh week in the
trial of father and son paul and ruben
flores as they're tried in the 1996
disappearance of kristen smart the cal
poly student went missing after a party
around memorial day weekend 26 years ago
witnesses say that paul who's charged
with her murder was the last person seen
with smart walking her home from the
party paul's father rubin is charged
with accessory after the fact for
allegedly helping hide the body by
burying her in his backyard and later
moving the remains jurors have now heard
from a former roommate who lived in
reuben's house as well as the contractor
who built the home now he was questioned
over practices that were used in the 90s
including colored twine and the use of
diesel fuel seemingly to explain items
that were found in the soil under
reuben's deck the roommate testified
that rubin would go out of his way to
avoid the area under the house and the
deck and asked him to avoid it as well
still ahead on long crime daily atlanta
officials announced the arrests of
alleged gang members in a years-long
investigation into celebrity home
invasions but first federal jurors hear
testimony from two more accusers who say
singer r kelly sexually abused them as
minors
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back everybody federal
prosecutors rest after more accusers
take the stand against disgraced rmb
singer r kelly as he stands trial in
federal court this comes as the 55 year
old convicted sex defender stands trial
in illinois for 13 federal sex crimes
charges now back in 2008 kelly was
acquitted by a cook county jury for
creating a video of himself having sex
with a 14 year old girl and at the time
the girl and her parents denied
involvement and they didn't testify but
this time around the alleged victim and
her mother testified saying that they
lied out of fear for their safety this
week jurors also heard from two more
accusers who say that their experiences
with the singer date back to the late
90s one woman using the pseudonym
pauline testified that she was in love
with kelly at the age of 14. she also
said that she was abused by kelly
hundreds of times another accuser using
only the name tracy told jurors kelly
ordered her into the bedroom and used
force to sexually assault her dozens of
times
mike we've heard this so many times
already and he we know he's already been
convicted in new york of illegal sex
acts and a widely publicized trial do
you think the jury can really set that
aside and judge this case based purely
on the facts that are being presented to
them
i think that's very difficult i know
jurors make that promise and i believe
they try
as best they can but
his
misdeeds and his abuse of young children
has just been all over the world quite
frankly and covered and i also really
wonder with his convictions why he would
even go through this again in another
trial where it's just going to be more
and more drawing attention to all the
wrongs he did and it seems like the
other conviction was very solid it's not
going to be one of those instances well
if i win that appeal maybe i can win
here i just don't see the point in the
sense of him going forward with this
trial and not coming to a resolution
where the victims don't have to testify
mike that is a great question that i'm
now gonna ask terry because we know
terry that he's facing criminal sex
charges in illinois and minnesota so
should he try to reach a global
resolution of all of these charges if
that's even possible
i definitely think he should try listen
he's got 10 counts of aggravated sexual
assault in illinois cook county and he's
got multiple
allegations as far as prostitution is
concerned in hennepin county and
minnesota and so i think it would
behoove him to try to get some sort of
global deal as you mentioned he had the
new york case where he's serving 30
years he's got this case now the federal
case in illinois the two state cases who
knows there might even be other cases
that crop up if i were his defense
counsel i would most definitely try to
get a deal where he could serve all of
his time out in federal prison and make
sure that you know you tack on some
additional time obviously for these
other crimes but to put these women
through this again and to spend all of
that money i think is a waste of time
and he's been consistent in his defense
saying that he's completely innocent
these women are not telling the truth
we'll continue to follow it we move over
now to
ohio where an attempted abduction is
caught on video showing a young girl
fighting for her life but as long crime
network sierra gillespie explains this
girl's reaction may have been what saved
her life
terrifying video appears to show the
attempted abduction of a six-year-old
girl who fought off the kidnapper just
feet from her front door
it happened on august 23rd in hamilton
ohio as six-year-old kennedy nash stood
outside her home a doorbell camera
captured the incident that happened in
just seconds when a man kennedy did not
know approached her video shows the man
walking up to kennedy he appears to
reach toward her before walking off he
then turns back and grabs her arm
that's when kennedy screams for help
highly highly disturbing stuff there
coming up on long crime daily the
defense highlights the gunman's middle
school years in the parkland school
shooter penalty phase trial plus more
than two dozen atlanta gang members are
behind bars after a string of celebrity
home break-ins and burglaries
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back atlanta area officials make
a massive break in their investigation
into a series of home invasions over the
last four years an indictment against
more than two dozen alleged gang members
accused of targeting celebrities and
other other wealthy homeowners singer
mariah carey real housewives of atlanta
star marlow hampton and atlanta falcons
player calvin ridley are among the
victims named at the news conference by
fulton county district attorney fannie
willis the 26 alleged gang members named
in the indictment include members of a
hybrid gang known as the drug rich gang
made up of members from the gangster
disciples and the bloods and the crips
willis says they targeted people who
showed their wealth on social media and
used information that was posted online
to their advantage to target them the
220 count indictment includes crimes
ranging from home invasions to
kidnapping armed robberies and shootings
willa says rap lyrics helped lead
investigators to those involved to which
she gave some advice saying quote don't
confess to crimes in rap lyrics if you
don't want them to be used
well terry so the rap lyrics apparently
helped the district attorney identify
these suspects but should she reveal
that information don't you kind of want
to keep that close i mean it could help
in future investigations if someone is
you know i don't know ill-advised in
spreading that all out on social media
absolutely you know i understand why she
did a press conference obviously she
wants to tell everyone about the case
and about the claims and the actions
that she's bringing against these
individuals and it's a big case it's a
lot of people and it's involving
celebrities but if i had been that
prosecutor i basically would have not
tipped my hat because you don't want as
you said jesse for the next group to be
aware of that and not put that
information in oftentimes in these songs
you do hear things about real life not
just rap songs any kind of song and so i
think that saying
she used that information is definitely
going to hurt her at the end of the day
and look the prosecution is obligated to
share anything that they have against
these individuals because obviously they
have to reveal their information that
makes these individuals culpable but you
don't have to reveal that that i think
is your source and your method as far as
i'm concerned well talking about what
you should reveal and not reveal mike
the alleged gang members targeted social
targeted people using their social media
accounts so do you think there should be
warnings by social media outlets about
this practice similar to the way there's
warnings on the subway to watch your
surroundings i think there needs to be a
warning out there for people you don't
have to put everything online
well you know you put an ad out there
enough that somebody's going to answer
it and i think that's one of the
problems with social media is people
no longer use it really to
share information it seems like more of
everybody wants to put out there that
they're leading the perfect life and
everything's perfect and nobody has any
down time and all my pictures on
instagram look great and that's the way
i am and i'm successful
that has a sort of reaction by people
who are trying to get their ways out of
bad situations financially or things of
that nature and i think it really almost
gives a road map to those who are into
illegal activities of who should be
their targets and i think that's a major
problem with it but terry rap lyrics are
is that really a strong form of evidence
at trial
well i think they can try to use that i
don't know if the judge is going to let
it in but it's definitely reflecting on
what these individuals are thinking and
it is in a way an admission so even
though it's an out of court statement
and it could be considered hearsay i do
think that if it's considered an
admission it could get in under that
exception so no doubt about it it's an
interesting case but who knows whether
or not that information is going to get
in it definitely helped her to bring
those charges but whether or not she's
able to use that during the trial is a
whole other question altogether yeah i
just think they see that it's subject to
interpretation we weren't really meaning
what we were saying i'd be curious to
see how that ultimately plays out well
netflix is facing more legal issues
surrounding its series inventing anna
this comes after a lawsuit is filed by
one of the real-life characters depicted
in the show now the show follows the
story of anna delvey whose real name is
anna sorokin scamming her way through
new york city it's actually based off of
the true story of the fake german
heiress who conned friends banks and
businessmen all in an attempt to fund
her life as a wannabe socialite her
former friend and vanity fair staffer
rachel delosh williams is suing the
streaming service over defamatory
statements she says were made in the
show in total the lawsuit states 16
separate sets of statements were made
about the former photo editor
one instance that williams says is
portrayed incorrectly is when is when
she took a trip to morocco with delvey
in the show she leaves the fake heiress
after her credit card has declined and
william says in her own book about the
relationship that she had already
planned on leaving early from the trip
her attorney says that scenes in the
show left williams exposed to online
hate after delvey was found out and
charged for her crimes she was convicted
in 2019 after just serving four years in
prison she was handed over to
immigration and customs enforcement as
she fights deportation to germany
when we come back the defense's case
continues in the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial hear from the
defendant's middle school counselor who
gives a closer look at his early years
[Music]
all right welcome back everybody so
jurors get a closer look at the
defendant's emotional and academic
issues when a middle school counselor
testifies in the parkland school shooter
penalty phase trial in february 2018 a
then 19 year old gunman opened fire at
marjory stoneman douglas high school 17
people were killed and 17 more were
injured last year that gunman pleaded
guilty to all counts meaning it's now up
to a florida jury to decide whether he
receives life in prison or the death
penalty as the defense enters week two
of its case the focus narrows in on the
gunman's childhood experiences on
tuesday the defendant's middle school
family counselor testified that he
wasn't a bully but instead was concerned
with how other people viewed him she
says west glades middle school did not
have the resources to assist with his
developmental issues and emotional
outbursts
a part of the notes is that nicholas
stated that he doesn't want to go to
west glade middle anymore
because he believes that he's wasting
other people's time
as he as he is always getting into
trouble
he expressed that he
believes
um well i'm sorry he expressed that he
is
basically behaving badly in hopes
that it will lead him into withdrawing
from the school and enrolling at another
school do you think westlakes was the
appropriate educational environment for
nicholas over time it became clear that
it was not
the appropriate place for him okay why
because
the resources that they had available
they
applied every resource that they
possibly could and they just did not
have
everything to be able to meet his knees
all the resources to meet his needs
there
so mike this counselor's role was to
provide
provide support for the defendant but
now did she actually help his defense
team
i think in a way she did because i think
it shows the frustration that
there was never anything to support him
as he was a child to deal with his
mental health issues and we're learning
more and more that when people have
those kind of issues as a child they
develop into bad situations in their
adult life and i think she was just
being frank and honest and i think that
gives credibility to the defense
well terry on cross-examination the
prosecutor tried to demonstrate that the
defendant was actually a bully and he
was able to conform his behavior he made
a choice do you think the process
prosecution was successful there
actually i think this was one of the
best cross-examinations i've seen and i
think it's underrated at this point
maybe people will recognize that listen
the defense is trying to show that this
defendant had a horrible childhood that
he was subject to drugs when he was in
utero that no one gave him the help that
he needed that he was bullied himself
but what the prosecution did was
cross-examine this counselor and pointed
out all of the horrible things that the
defendant did so for instance he tore
out a bathroom sink and he cursed out
teachers he threw things at the other
students he was extremely disruptive and
at one point the prosecutor asked this
counselor who was on the stand
listen you said on direct
that he was not a bully do you still
think based on all of this that he was
not a bully and she basically admitted
you're right he was a bully and the
prosecutor said thank you so i do think
it was effective cross-examination and i
think it was a big point because that
jury is looking at this case and
thinking well he was a bully he had a
decent
childhood with his adopted family and so
perhaps he should get the death penalty
because you know obviously it was a
horrific crime that occurred and there's
no excuse for it under any circumstances
so i think good job well i tell you this
is not an easy task for a jury a lot for
them to ultimately decide mike terry
thanks so much everyone out there thanks
for joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you